Hey Andy, so how'd it go this time?
>> Pretty terribly.
It probably took about ten times longer to get five cats working than it
did for two.
Which doesn't make a lot of sense.
>> Oh that's rough.
>> Yeah. I had a lot of divs, if that's, is that a good thing?
[LAUGH] A lot of divs with cats and
buttons and, you know, cat one, cat two, cat three.
And I tried to, in the JavaScript file, iterate over all of those.
And bind the buttons to the counters for
the different cats, but everything kept, kept getting down to the very last cat.
>> Mm. That was that closure issue we were talking about.
>> It was.
That was where the 10x time increase came from, was figuring that out.
But I mean it's working.
So, that's good.
But, I, I, I don't want to keep making things this way.